you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines uh
with
ali mirage and christina patterson there
they both are so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
well queen camilla gets royal approval
that's the headline on the sunday
telegraph as her majesty expresses her
sincere wish for the duchess of cornwall
to one day be known as queen consort
camilla will be queen on the front of
the sunday mirror
the observer leads with the latest on
partygate and growing pressure on boris
johnson the comments from one
backbencher says the pm's departure is
inevitable
the express leads on his bullish plan to
get his back benches on side with a
three-point deal in an attempt to secure
their support
while the sunday times has a report on
exam results and grade inflation during
the pandemic
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and uh joining me tonight christina
patterson ali mirage welcome to both of
you let's start with the telegraph queen
camilla gets royal approval uh
unprecedented the queen should make this
announcement uh but also unprecedented
that she's going to be celebrating and
is celebrating a platinum jubilee but a
shock this announcement though christina
well i don't i'm not sure how much of a
shock it is but i must say it's nice to
get some good news in the midst of what
seems to be a litany of rather
depressing stories and to see the
smiling queen reach a landmark that no
other monarch has reached before is is
in my view cheering i'm not particularly
monacas but i'm a huge fan of the queen
i think she's done an incredible job and
she's an amazing person actually and she
really has spent all this time devoted
to public service she made a vow she's a
committed christian she took that vow
seriously and she has kept it
and camilla has also done an incredible
job she was unpopular understandably
after the princess diana death and when
prince charles got together with
camilla but she has also put in years
and years of public service and she
seems to be i never met her but she
seems an extremely down to a loyal
loving hard-working person very
committed to the arts and literature and
um i'm really pleased for her and i i
think it's it's lovely to have this
cheerful announcement at the moment
ali do you think it's a surprise that uh
she's basically said her wish would be
for camilla to be queen console
i don't think it's a huge surprise but i
think it's uh hugely significant and
very welcome and i think what it does
show
is that the queen is recognizing the
fact that
camilla has quietly got on with the job
in a very decent dignified manner
attracting very little attention to
herself and is really warm to the role
that she is going to that she has been
playing for many years
as the
right hand of her husband uh prince
charles who will become king one day and
i think this is a recognition that the
queen in her utter professionalism as we
always expect from her majesty is now
looking to the future and wants us to
ensure that her people are fully
informed about her intentions and that
the succession is planned and people are
aware of what's going to happen and i
think look prince charles is going to
have a lot of adjusting to do when he
goes into that role he's very outspoken
he cares about a lot of issues the
environment architecture a whole range
of things that he's been
outspoken about over many many years
he's going to have to temper that and he
needs a wise head by his side and
camilla and i think uh christina is
right about this from being deeply
unpopular has turned it right round
and has done her job with great
employment i think that's uh this is
recognition from her majesty uh for that
yes and the mirror also uh reporting on
that story camilla will be queen a
monarch's historic announcement in her
platinum jubilee message but the actual
uh title um as it will be will be queen
consort
won't it christina
yes yes well i mean she well she will be
addressed as her majesty uh which is um
an acknowledgement of her status and i
mean
implied sense i'm afraid you know i do
think some of these titles are slightly
ridiculous in 2022 but but as a mark of
respect i think it's important and uh
she has to be consoled because she
obviously um you know charles divorced
before marrying her but i think she'll
be happy charles will be happy and this
will be a way of marking the future with
a degree of happiness and and uh a
forward-looking approach which i think
will be very much appreciated by charles
and camilla and by the nation actually
to the observer ali and uh a warning
from a boris johnson loyalist saying
that his removal is actually inevitable
it is what is to come and the script
can't be rewritten
well um
look i've been putting the boots into
the prime minister which has been pretty
easy to do for the last few months
because it's been
one a series of unforced errors starting
with the owen patterson debacle over
second jobs uh to uh issues over uh what
uh text messages should have been
disclosed to lord guy over wallpaper in
the prime minister's flat to all these
en endless stories about parties which
uh are not going away i mean the first
rule in the conservative press office
used to be that you put a story to bed
as quickly as possible this is going to
go on for weeks we've had sue gray's
redacted update we're still waiting for
cressida dick's report but we are also
still waiting for the 54 letters uh
threshold to be reached and it hasn't
been uh so i'm still i think the jury's
still out about whether the prime
minister's going to go or not i think
the serious thing that's happened this
evening however is if he is serious
about saving his premiership he's
showing this evening
that he means business he's brought in
steve barclay and gito harry both in um
to help him steve barclay as chief of
staff he's already the cabinet minister
and gito harry who worked with him at uh
uh during his time as mayor of london
now steve barclay is a serious player
he's a diligent hard-working competent
minister who's been not only uh
in charge of secretary of state for
brexit but also chief secretary to the
treasury he's very he's on very good
terms of risky sonnet and boris johnson
works down the corridor from boris
johnson highly competent ex-lawyer
ex-army officer got experience in the
private sector the financial services
authority and also struggled to get into
parliament got in on his third attempt
so he's not some fly-by-night person who
was parachuted into a safe seat one of
the most credible
decent hard-working people uh in the
government i've known him for a long
time and gito harry again a serious
player lots of media experience was at
the bbc for
uh 17 odd years has worked in various
roles i think this shows that if the
prime minister is going to turn around
and it's a big if because it felt really
like hammer tonight at the london
palladium for far too long
uh this might just be it yes it
certainly uh seems as as though he is
going to to fight but yet we have this
loyalist the charles walker saying that
uh it's an inevitable tragedy uh saying
that the prime minister's student of
greek and roman tragedy it is going to
end in him going um so i just want him
to have some agency in that so a
loyalist there to the prime minister
pleading
essentially for him to go uh himself
christina
well sir charles walker is an incredibly
decent man i mean he's announced this
week that he's standing down as an mp
and it was a rather touching interview
when he said he was exhausted by the
whole thing he'd give it enough but he
he just his decency shines through
actually and i think he's genuinely
wanting it's saying this out of kindness
to boris johnson because he can see that
the writing on the wall i think it is
inevitable that boris johnson goes i'm
i'm sort of a bit torn because i think i
think he's a dreadful man and a dreadful
prime minister and i think he has
completely dragged the reputation of our
country through the mud and what to go
back to what ali said about unforced
areas these are not unforced errors the
error was made throughout rock lockdown
when the person who made the law in this
country and put down the strictest
regulations outside uh in peacetime
consistently broke those and we don't
need to wait for a police report or sue
grey's you know next versions at you
know sue grey version two of her report
we absolutely absolutely clear that he
broke the law and he wrote the
regulations so and the country has
already made its mind up about that it's
it's evident from all the polls and any
mp will tell you that their inboxes have
been full of complaints and certainly
die-hard tories i know who are not
particularly um
party you know they're not tribe but
they're not tribal but they're also not
politic politically engaged particularly
they are furious with boris johnson
people who made enormous sacrifices so i
think this idea that re-jigging the
chairs on the titanic and bringing in
some strong men and
changing your policies madly swinging
wildly from throwing money at
voters and particularly voters in the
red world to suddenly becoming a tax
cutting conservative and all of this
makes it absolutely clear that boris
johnson has no vision no political
thoughts of his own that he's simply
influenced by the latest person to
whisper into his ear whether that be
carrie johnson or tory back bunches of
the 1922 committee so i mean he can do
all this and but he will go i don't know
how long it will take i would quite like
him to stay because polls show that um
if he stays he's likely to lose the next
election and obviously i'm very keen for
the tories to lose the next election yes
but it's clearly absolutely you're
absolutely clear clear about that but
but it's also clear that he does have a
a survival plan um and of the things
that we've spoken about already this
evening for the moment uh both of you do
stay with us uh we are going to take a
break but coming up the press preview
continues including this story in the
sunday times their headline private
schools gained covid to boost grades
stay with us
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me christina
patterson and ali mirage let's take a
look at the sunday times and this story
about uh similarly about private schools
um
manipulating or grade inflation in terms
of uh the a stars that have been handed
out
during corona virus uh explain the story
and take us into it christina
well it seems from not all the um
the full data isn't out yet but
according to uh what has been published
already it's clear that many private
schools have managed to hugely increase
the number of their students who got a
starred grade this was introduced in
2010 to
um
to indicate a particular achievement and
some schools have gone up from sort of
10 12 15
of a star grades to 90 percent rishi
sunax old school winchester i think they
went up to something like 82 percent and
it seems that essentially what has
happened is that while so many people so
many children in this country have had a
really really tough time with their
education not helped by having possibly
the most hapless education secretary in
history gavin williamson who's just
couldn't have made more of a mess of
educating children during the pandemic
and of the exams situation absolute
fiasco meanwhile the seven percent of
the population that go to private
schools have had their life chances
improved yet again with these inflated
grades so i must say it's it's rather
upsetting and demoralizing for the vast
variety of the population who are not
getting these opportunities for
inflation let's just move on because
we're running out of time to the uh
telegraph the sunday telegraph um ally
and this story about uh expenses nhs
trusts spending three million pounds on
expenses on recruitment trips to to uh
recruit doctors from overseas
well yes sir this is a story saying that
uh
various trusted spend up to nine
thousand pounds per head trying to
recruit
medics to come and work in the country
clearly we've got a
severe skill shortages up to about 100
000
vacancies within the nhs and various
trusts have been going out to different
countries with delegations to try and
woo people to come here it does seem
like
a slightly interesting use of public
funds to do this but the reality is that
we do have a skills shortage on the back
of brexit we are restricting immigration
and we're not going to go down the road
of unfettered immigration with all the
problems that had but in the meantime
whilst we
train more doctors and nurses that's
going to take time it's not going to
happen overnight so various measures
have to be taken why they couldn't do
this remotely and why they had to go in
person
seems a little bit strange but um
certainly it doesn't seem to be the best
use of taxpayers money and i think it
should be investigated and probably
should not happen again
yes uh very good point you you make
findings revealed under freedom of
information that as many as nine people
were sent on the overseas trips at a
time it does seem excessive
for the moment thank you both we shall
see you at 11 30. thank you
in the meantime let's have a look at the
weather for you
you